this might be a good place to uh you
already mentioned it but what is
contrastive learning and what are
energy-based models
contrastive learning is sort of the
paradigm of learning where
the idea is that you are learning this
embedding space or so you're learning
this sort of vector space of
all your concepts and the way you learn
that is basically by contrasting so the
idea is that you have
a sample you have another sample that's
related to it so that's
called the positive and you have another
sample that's not related to it so
that's negative
so for example let's just take an nlp or
one in a simple example in uh computer
vision so
you have an image of a cat you have an
image of a dog
and for whatever application that you're
doing say you're trying to figure out
what
pets are you think that these two images
are related so image of a cat and dog
are related
but now you have another third image of
a banana
because you don't like that word so now
you basically have this banana thank you
for speaking to the crowd
and so you take both of these images and
you take the image from the cat the
image from the dog you get a feature
from both of them
and now what you're training the network
to do is basically pull
both of these features together while
pushing them away from the feature of a
banana
so this is the contrastive part so
you're contrasting against the banana
so there's always this notion of a
negative and a positive
now energy based models are like like
one way that
uh yan sort of explains a lot of these
methods so
yarn basically i think a couple of years
or more than that like when i joined
facebook
uh jan used to keep mentioning this word
energy based models and of course i had
no idea what he was talking about
so then one day i caught him in one of
the conference rooms and i'm like can
you please tell me what this is so then
like very patiently he sat down with
like a marker and a white board
and his idea basically is that rather
than talking about probability
distributions you can talk about
energies of models so
models are trying to minimize certain
energies in certain space or they're
trying to maximize
a certain kind of energy and the idea
basically is that
you can explain a lot of the contrastive
models gans for example which are like
generative adversarial networks a lot of
these modern learning methods or vis
which are variational auto encoders you
can really explain them very nicely
in terms of an energy function that
they're trying to minimize or maximize
and so by putting this common sort of
language for all of these models
what looks very different in machine
learning that oh vaes are very different
from what gans are very very different
from what contrasting models are you
actually get a sense of like oh these
are actually
very very related it's just that the way
or the mechanism
in which they're sort of maximizing or
minimizing this energy function is
slightly different
so revealing the the commonalities
between all these approaches
and putting a sexy word on top of it
like energy and so similarities
two things that are similar have low
energy like the low energies
signifying similarity right exactly so
basically the idea is that if you were
to imagine like the embedding as a
manifold a 2d manifold you would get a
hill or like a high sort of peak in the
energy manifold
wherever two things are not related and
basically you would have like a dip
where two things
are related so you'd get a dip in the
manner and uh in the self-supervised
context
how do you know two things are related
and two things are not related right
so this is where all the sort of
ingenuity or tricks comes in right
so for example like uh you can take the
fill in the blank problem or you can
take in the the context problem
and what you can say is two words that
are in the same context are related
two words that are in different contexts
are not related for images
basically two crops from the same image
are related and whereas a third image is
not related
at all for a video it can be two frames
from that video related because they're
likely to
contain the same sort of concepts in
them whereas a third frame from a
different video is not related
so it basically is it's a very general
term contrasting loading is nothing
really to do with self-supervised
learning it
actually is very popular for for example
like any kind of metric learning or
any kind of embedding learning so it's
also used in supervised learning
it's all and the thing is because we are
not really using labels to get these
positive or negative
pairs it can basically also be used for
self-supervised learning
you